العالم الرياضي ولكن زاويه مختلفه تماما
الاستثمار رياضيا في الابناء لصناعه
الثروه 10,000 من اللاعبين المحترفين حول
العالم مكانه ليصلوا الى المجد لو استثمار
اهلهم فيهم فهم اثرياء والاهل ايضا اصبحوا
اثرياء اليوم من والد نيمار الى والد ميسي
واسرته الداعمه ووالده بابي وكريستيانو
رونالدو وغيرها كلهم راحوا واستثمر في
الابناء فجلبوا لهم الملايين اليوم لا شك
ان ملايين الاسر حول العالم
في الابناء الرياضيه
لنتوقف اولا مع ثروات اللاعبين مع علاء
اذا تصنيف جديد لمجالات فورد الامريكيه
حول الرياضيين الاعلى اجرا في العالم حيث
وجاء النجم البرتغالي كريستيانو رونالدو
المنتقل حديثا الى نادي النصر السعودي على
راس القائمه بنحو 200 مليون دولار نجم
الكره
في المركز الثاني كاكثر الرياضيين دخلا في
العالم بنحو
125 مليون دولار اما المركز الثالث فذهب
لنجم كره السله الامريكي الذي حقق دخلا
يزيد عن مئه و 21 مليون دولار ذهب المركز
الرابع لنجم الكره الارجنتيني المتوج بكاس
العالم الاخيره ليونيل ميسي والذي حقق
دخلا وصل الى 100 110 ملايين دولار امريكي
جاء النجم البرازيلي نيمار في المركز
الخامس برقمي بداخيل وصلت الى خمسه وتسع
مليون دولار امريكي
[موسيقى]
القاهره الصحفي الرياضي محمد حامد محمد
يسعد صباحك نرجع نفتح ملف قنوات اللاعبين
وكيف الاستثمار في الابناء وهم صغار ليكبر
ويصبحوا لاعبين محترفين وبالتالي تصبح
عائلاتهم من اغنياء العالم حديثنا اكثر عن
هذا الاستثمار في لبنان
احنا دايما بنقول ال ال الطموحه القمر في
اسوا الحالات سوف يمسك بالنجوم بمعنى انه
العالم كله في 275 مليون لاعب كره قدم
منهم فقط 129.000 محترف
يتقاضوا رواتب عاليه يعني زيرو
زيرو زيرو فور 7 المحترفين واللي بيستفيده
ماديا من كره القدم ولكن هذا يعني ابدا ان
لا يكون لدي طموح يعني لماذا لا يكون ابني
هو ميسي لماذا لا يكون ابني هو نيمار
فبالتالي باب الطموح مفتوح ومشروع بكل
تاكيد ولكن يجب على الاباء ان يتمتعه
بدرجه من الوعي في التخطيط لابنائهم في
هذا الطريق والمساله فيها الكثير من
التفاصيل
يعني بين الموهبه الكرويه وبين الصناعه
الكرويه هل يمكن ان تتفوق الصناعه الكرويه
على لاعب موهوب بالفطره اصلا
المساله فعلا في فرق بين موهبه وصناعه اا
مش بالضروره يعني مثلا لو احنا بنتكلم عن
الرياضه بشكل مطلق او كره القدم كاحتراف
ومصدر للدخل للعائله وال- ولطفل اللي بعد
كده هيكون شاب او لاعب محترف لو بنتكلم عن
كره القدم تحديدا مش بالضروره كل عناصر
الفريق او التيم يكونوا موجودين يعني
دائما بنقول كره القدم هي تيمورك في شخص
موجود جدا ميسي في شخص فايتر مثلا خلينا
نقول اسمه في شخص حارس مرمى حسب الموهبه
وحسب القدرات باختصار يستطيع الاهلي
اكتشاف همم ميول ابنهم لكره القدم وليس
بالضروره موهبه خارقه مش ضروري يعني بعد
كده ممكن خضوع لمساله التدريب في
اكاديميات وتدريب في ليفل معين يصنع منه
لاعب كره قدم جيد وبرده باكد على المعلومه
مش بالضروره كل الاطفال اللي في العالم او
كل من يريد ان يلعب كره قدم سوف يكون
مارادونا او ميسي او رونالدو طيب محمد
بالنسبه للاباء او لدي الذين لديهم اولاد
هل الاهم اليوم الموهبه والفطره ام
الاهتمام والرعايه منذ الصغر وما هي نصائح
التي تقدمها لهم حتى يصبح محترفين في
المستقبل
انت في البدايه بتستكشف ابنك
وميوله لممارسه كره القدم بعد كده الخطوه
التاليه ان انا ابحث له عن مكان للتدريب
والتقييم
ومن النصائح المهمه في في هذا المجال انه
لازم يعرض على اكثر من اكاديميه كرويه
واكثر من مدرب لان كل مدرب عنده رؤيه
بيستكشف في موهبه معينه كمان مهم جدا ان
انا ابدا ده في اي عمر المساله بتبدا
تحديدا من خمس سنوات الى 12 سنه ابتدي
اكتشف موهبه ابني وقدرته على دخوله هذا
العالم بعد ذلك من النصائح المهمه ان يكون
فيه بلانس في توازن ما بين ممارسه كره
القدم بهدف ان انا عندي طرجه اوصل لمستوى
احترافي والدراسه دائما الدراسه نخليها
فلان يوازي فلان ممارسه كره القدم احنا
بنتكلم عن منطقتنا وثقتنا ما بنتكلمش بشكل
مطلق انا انا انا متاكد واكيد انتم كمان
بالتاكيد متاكدين ان مساله الدراسه
والمستقبل الدراسي
جدا لينا في ثقافتنا هيكون في البلد بين
الاثنين اللاعب
بدي افهم منك يعني العائلات
بابنائهم يعني
بالصوت هيك الموضوع ولا فعلا كان في مخطط
عشان يعرفوا العائلات الثانيه والامهات
الثانيه كيف سنستثمر في ابنائنا مستقبلا
اللي نجحوا دي حقيقه بالمناسبه اللي نجحوا
مش بالصدفه نجحوا بدون ما ما الاهل او
اللاعب نفسه يكون عنده اعتقاد ما فيش ضمان
في الحياه يعني ما فيش جلانتيز في الحياه
ابدا يعني يعني انا ما اقدرش اضمن ابني
مهما كان موهبته وفي النهايه هيكون محمد
صلاح ويكون ما شاء الله مثلا راتبه
الثانوي 20 او 30 مليون يورو او دولار ما
اقدرش اضمن دي بس كل اللي اقدر اعمله
اوديه اخده الى مكان همم اكاديميه لممارسه
اللعبه واكتشاف موهبته بعد ذلك ادعمه اعمل
نوع من التوازن في حياته اشجعه بين
الدراسه وبين ممارسه كره القدم مستوى
احترافي في المستوى الاعلى من كده لو
الولد موهوب واتضحت موهوبته في عمر خلينا
نقول 14 15 16 ليه لا معرضوش على اكاديميه
عالميه ليه ما وافقش على وجوده في مدرسه
داخليه او اكاديميه تجمع بين الدراسه
وممارسه كره القدم في افريقيا بيعملوا كده
اللاعب الافريقي او الشعب او المراهق
بياخذ من سن 15 16 سنه في مدرسه داخليه في
اوروبا او اكاديميه وما بين الدراسه
وممارسه كره القدم لما بيوصل لسن 17 و18
سنه هنا الحكم النهائي سوف يكون لاعب كره
قدم محترف وله مستقبل ام لا شكرا جزيلا لك
من القاهره الصحفي الرياضي محمد حامد شكرا
يا محمد